hey guys is Eric Nam and I'm here at
BuzzFeed to read this Pandora's box of
thirst tweets all right I'm gonna say it
Eric Nam is daddy material hey how do
you respond to that like what do you say
go to bed that's what daddies say right
if I'm emotional for the next few days
it's because I saw Eric Nam and his hot
level was through the roof and he was
using his bedroom toys half the time
during the concert like what the and
that's I for this did I use my bedroom
voice I didn't know that I made people
feel that way during shows I give TED
talks during my concert
Eric Nam could punch me in the face and
I'd give him both of my kidneys well
I'll be sure not to punch you in the
face because I don't want you to die you
need your kidneys to survive okay
a lot of aggression right there all
right Eric Nam has big dick energy and
big heart energy thank you appreciate it
all that big dick energy coming to you
and big heart energy in this new album
we are not worthy of your thigh cleavage
you killed me now I don't have die
cleavage guys I this is almost insulting
I have like chopsticks four legs and I
don't use the word chopsticks cuz I'm
Asian it's because literally they're
just like toothpicks I've never heard
that term mom and I'm said not too sexy
but then waves are the cause of many
deaths at night there are a lot of waves
what a body rolls a lot of waves that go
on in my shows my mom does not approve
she's not a fan she literally told me to
tone down the sexiness she said too much
sexy God is watching you sorry God she
should not watch this video mom's gonna
be you could sing baby shark for two
hours and I'd still give you all my
money
I appreciate that baby shark do do do do
do it baby shudder to do that thing is
like it like gets in your head sexuality
Eric Nam singing trekker it's all those
high notes but people get really really
excited from it like I play that song
and people just
use your imagination I need Eric Nam
shirtless photos right now I'm just
gonna save you the effort and the energy
and I think your imagination is probably
much better than the reality that's
going on under this leopard print so you
can imagine like the abs and like the
big you know pecs and everything it's
actually not happening so let it live
and thrive in your brain I saw Eric Nam
in a good light earlier and I choked on
my spit
damn poppy you think I've never had
anybody speaks to me in this way but I
like it I'm all about it honestly Eric
not to choke my ass out and I would
still think in wonder I feel like you
made this up like one of the two of you
were like we need some really
controversial it's not choke people
let's not many people die pass out but
again I appreciate the comments Pam this
is like really aggressive oh man you
guys are so aggressive step on me I'm
not gonna step on you I will like love
tap you or like love kick you but I'm
not gonna step on you stepping on people
hurts man if you pay me enough I think
anything's possible people are gonna
think I'm crazy from this all right Eric
you're out here really out here looking
like coal snack can you let me breathe
yes kids a quick breathing exercise
everybody you can breathe in through
your nose on the other hand Eric Nam's
body gives me an ore chest his voice is
so hot I mean if you feel that from the
music I'm all about it appreciate it
I haven't said these words in so long
like these were I live in Korea y'all
like I'm not having conversations we're
like your body gives me an or yeah like
what you look like that hot bad boy it's
just a little misunderstood and needs a
nice girl to help and be a better
version of myself Eric I could be that
nice girl
I look like the hot bad boy I'm like the
most soft marshmallow soft nice boy ever
this is his last one this is the last
one I hope it's epic I want to see Eric
Nam but I'm afraid he will only look at
my bus earlier this year I wrote on like
a tweet or like
Instagram I was like 2019 let's get busy
I smelled busy with a bunch of s's not
knowing that that was a thing people
went wild on that and I was like yo I'm
just saying I just said busy you know
like no you definitely said something
else
and I now know how do you pronounce it
though oh yeah BuzzFeed business we're
tapping mom's definitely gonna call I'm
so screwed
[Music]
[Music]